oh Alô Oi querido tudo bem para comprar
as coisas para gente fazer aqui é coisa
de Páscoa aqui em casa só não compra
carne porque é pecado tá não compra
menino diabo Satanás tá de semana pegar
tão ruim eu podia te matar de uma pizza
Pera aí que eu tô falando com teu pai
amor não compra carne porque é pecado
comer carne na semana santa não precisa
só de falar coisas tu viu se tu ficou
sabendo da Claudinha aqui é que fez os
vídeos pornográficos fez passou no
WhatsApp amor que vagabundo não amor tem
negócio de foi sem querer o namorado não
que faz as coisas vagabunda tem que ir
para o inferno morrer mesmo tá só não
compra carne é pecado comer carne tá
amor compra cachaça muita cachaça vamos
se beber da depois vamos dirigir
atropelar pessoas várias carne não não
compra carne